[MUSIC]
Hi.
Today we will talk about the arms race
between the researchers trying
to develop an HIV vaccine, and
the rapidly evolving human
immunodeficiency virus.
And this discussion will bring us to
the challenge of comparing highly diverse
viruses from different patients, or
comparing highly diverse proteins
from species separated by
millions of years of evolution.
We will learn that the traditional
sickness alignment algorithm
that we studied before
often fails to detect
subtle similarity between
highly diverged sequences.
To address this limitation, we will
develop a new computational framework
called Hidden Markov Models,
whose applications in
bioinformatics will extend well
beyond sequence comparison.
We will start from classifying
HIV phenotypes, and
asking the question of what HIV
phenotype Gaëtan Dugas had.
Gaëtan Dugas was a flight attendant
who traveled the world and
engaged in sexual liaison
with hundreds of men.
In 1984, he has become the most
studied HIV patient in the world,
when biologists constructed
a network of 40 HIV patients
whom he infected with his HIV virus.
He died in the same year and
was named AIDS patient zero,
although, of course, he was not
the first HIV patient.
In the same year, the U.S. Health Secretary,
Margaret Heckler, announced that an HIV
vaccine is about to be developed.
13 years later, Bill Clinton said:
"It's no longer a question of
whether we can develop an AIDS vaccine;
it is simply a question of when."
Well, we still don't have
an HIV vaccine today,
and to understand why we don't have it,
it's important to figure out how
HIV evades the human immune systems.
Vaccines are often made from
virus surface proteins to train
the human immune system to recognize
vital envelope proteins and destroy them.
However, the strategy didn't work for
HIV viruses because HIV evolves so
fast that there is actually
a multitude of various HIV subtypes.
This slide shows ten sequences from
HIV envelope glycoprotein gp120
that shows a large number of substitutions,
insertions, and
deletions within a single patient.
HIV viruses in a single patient
evolve with a very
fast rate of 2% per nucleotide per year.
HIV strains in different patients are so
diverged that they require
different drug cocktails.
Today we will talk about one specific
HIV phenotype called
syncytium-inducing phenotype.
HIV has the ability to trick human cells
to fuse together together
to form one giant cell.
Why would the HIV virus do
such a strange thing?
Because it's easier to kill all the cells
once they are fused in a single cell.
The question we will be interested in today:
"Given an HIV sequence,
can we figure out whether it has
a syncytium-inducing phenotype or not?"
And in this slide,
you see 20 sequences from protein gp120
actually, from a spectacularly conserved
region of this protein called the V3 loop.
Despite the fact that it's conserved,
the sequences have many mutations
and even have different lengths, so
we would definitely need to align them.
We know that six of these sequences
have syncytium-inducing phenotype,
but what sequence features
define this syncytium-inducing phenotype?
Biologists noticed that in HIV viruses
with the syncytium-inducing phenotype,
the amino acids at positions 11 and 25
of the V3 region are Arginine and
Leucine, and it has become
the first computational rule for
classifying the syncytium-inducing phenotype.
It later turned out that the classifying
rules are much more complex, but
we will not go into the details
of the more complex rules.
What we will, however, notice
is that when we construct this alignment
and build a profile and
sequence logo from this alignment,
we will see the conservation
of sequences is extremely
non-uniform across different positions.
For example, positions 11 and 25
are particularly poorly in this case.
And this brings one challenge and
one question: the challenge is
to predict an HIV phenotype.
It is very important to
align sequences correctly.
In our case, alignment of the
V3 region is not difficult.
We can figure out that
all V3 regions
belong to the same type of proteins.
However, aligning them correctly
so that all amino acids
belonging to columns 11 and 25 appear in
the same column may become a challenge.
And it brings the following question:
Was it a good idea to use
the same scoring matrix
across different columns of an alignment,
something we have done in our previous
studies of multiple alignment?
And a brief look at this sequence logo
tells us that we should develop a new
statistically solid problem
formulation for alignment
that will use a different scoring
approach at different columns.